jared is with us in dayton ohio
hi Jared how are you better than I
deserve how can I help you really expect
me to man up and you know take on this
desk
all of my family I'm honored sir thank
you $52,000 and a bang at about 49,000
combined so obviously I see we need some
more income I'm looking to enroll to be
my house a real estate license next laws
hopefully do my job we have an
educational program where they was you
know pay for schooling good so I just
want something by song you know where to
go from here okay what kind of debt is
the 52,000 and she has about 6,000 and
signal and then I have some some credit
card bed and she has a little credit
card gate as well mm-hmm okay all right
well tonight I would sit down and open
the every dollar app and begin to do
your budget with your wife and start to
talk about what have we got to do to
take this income that we have plus any
income we can create extra and get out
of debt what's the fastest thing we're
going to do then as soon as you're
having that meeting I would get out some
scissors and cut up every one of those
credit cards they've obviously not been
a blessing to you correct every one of
them and get debit cards if you don't
have them already for your checking
account and you don't spend money that
you don't have starting today ready set
go okay and then I'm gonna start asking
myself a question about these cars
because you know well over half of your
death 32,000 of the 52 is cars right you
got a car problem so yeah I mean you
know if you didn't have any car payments
you would have only $20,000
the debt making 40 pick up an extra job
you'd be debt-free in a year if you
didn't have car payments you see what
I'm saying now so I'm thinking about one
or both of these being gone if I'm you
and get me a couple thousand dollar two
thousand dollar paid for cars and let
everybody make fun of me that's just
fine but I got no payments and then we
can save up and move up in car later
with cash
but the rule of thumb is this you
shouldn't even if they're paid for you
should not own things with motors and
Wheels motors or wheels that it total
more than half your annual income so
your tractors and sea-doos and boats and
motorcycles and cars and four-wheelers
and Gators and whatever else you want to
buy like that all added together should
never be more than half your annual
income because you've got too much tied
up in things that go down in value and
everything with a motor goes down in
value with the exception of the
occasional classic car and nobody's ever
really made that argument successfully
some of them go up in value and it's a
collector's thing that becomes an
investment for somebody actually knows
what they're doing but that's not we're
talking about here we're talking about
rolling stock goes down and you got
32,000 dollars worth of cars our car
dead anyway all of the cars are worth
that with a $50,000 income so you're
over half or at one time you were over
half of your income you have too much in
cars even if they were paid for you have
too much tied up in cars and because
they go down in value I'm not against
you having a nice car I'm against your
nice car having you and you got car itis
over there brother so that's what I
would do if I were in your shoes and
hang on I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover and show
you exactly what to do and how to do it
and Kelly I'll pick up and get one of
those out too